this is a production of cornell
university
thanks to all our attendees for for
uh registering today for the live
webinar um for those of you watching on
the recording obviously this is on
youtube
so you guys can watch on demand
this is the the fourth webinar in our
series uh related to our environmental
results program
uh so this has been a joint effort
between uh the new york state pollution
prevention institute p2i center
us at the cornell turf grass program uh
myself carl scamenti and dr frank rossi
the the new york turf grass extension
specialist and associate professor here
at cornell
and then of course rick slattery so
former superintendent
at locust tale and a variety of other
facilities
rick's been integral in this project
giving us that superintendent point of
view
and this this whole project is really
aimed at improving bmp adoption
so again for those not familiar this is
kind of a four-step process
the first step being you know let's
really target a couple bmps
and make a survey
uh and the second step was
to evaluate evaluate uh the adoption of
those various bmps in our local region
so we're looking at central and western
new york and so based on all that survey
data we got back
we went to an outreach phase step three
so you can call it intervention
but this has been kind of a
multi-pronged approach
we've been doing these webinars for
example we're going to be doing a couple
field days here
this come this coming year
and we're going to have resources online
so you can go on to our website i'll
throw these links in the chat you can
find a bunch of case studies and a bunch
of resources nutrient management plan
spill control checklist we'll talk about
that today
uh in this infograp graphic poster so uh
this step free process is really us
targeting um
increasing certain emps that we found
required um improvement and then the
step four will be at the end of this
year we'll go back in and survey and see
how we did you know did we improve
adoption rates
uh that's what we'll have to see
so basically we've got these four
categories that we've separated bmds
into
um and today we're going to talk about
the last one that we haven't done a
webinar yet uh which is pollution and
and i think the p word uh maybe people
in our industry don't like to say it
very much
pollution but we're going to talk today
a little bit about the perception and
the reality of pollution
on golf courses so
as you guys know the public doesn't
necessarily view golf courses kindly
when it comes to
environmental concerns you can just do a
simple twitter search or
recently a cnn article with a with a
pretty
inflammatory visual there on the front
of it right a golf ball and a hellscape
i think that represents you know the
general public view of golf courses
that we're applying all these chemicals
and
and sometimes you see that bleed into
some some potential policies so for
example in new york this
uh didn't go through but proposed
legislation that um
you know you know i would say is
questionable is that gonna actually help
the problem do they understand really
what's going on in golf courses
um so the reality is that uh you know in
the last two decades we've been
decreasing our fertilizer use
this is data from the gcsaa that's
showing
significant decreases in nitrogen
phosphorus and potassium use
um and the other thing is looking at
pesticide use on golf courses this
hasn't been something
you can really find in literature
anywhere
frank and i were fortunate enough to
partner up with some folks at university
of
wisconsin
and kind of look at
you know pesticide use on golf courses
and compare that to other land use types
right so when people say oh that golf
course is using uh too many pesticides
you know what would that turn into and
you know maybe that land use type could
may use more pesticides so for example
in our research if we normalize all the
pesticide use on 180 acres of a golf
course property
uh the e-i-eq this is a way to model
pesticide risk
is uh you know in the 200 range when you
compare that to something like an apple
orchard
uh vineyard or or a potato farm it's
actually substantially less
um so this is just again kind of putting
into perspective the the amount of
pesticides we use you know we're
generally treating
down the middles right teas greens some
of us are treating fairways but there's
a whole lot of peripheries of the golf
course that aren't receiving chemical
applications and i think this sort of
research gets us closer to people
understanding that
um so at the same time we're using less
we're using less fertilizer and less
pesticides every year but there is going
to be some that leaks out to the
environment
so a really cool meta study from from
the folks at virginia tech back in
easton uh we're going to lose some
nitrogen that we apply we're going to
lose some phosphorus that leeches
and when you look at our golf course
water bodies again this is a meta study
from
uh from 2010 looking at a bunch of
different other studies measuring water
quality on golf courses you know we got
a pretty high percentage of our our
waters that
have elevated levels of nitrogen most of
them have elevated levels of phosphorus
but pesticides not so much so there's a
little disconnect there we've got a lot
of nutrients
not a whole lot of pesticides in our
water
but there's reasons for that
so the first reason is legacy nutrients
you know we saw that graph earlier that
we've reduced fertilizer use over the
years
a lot of those nutrients are going to be
in the system for a long time and
they're going to continue to leak out
long after we've applied them
so even though we're reducing nitrogen
and phosphorus rates now
there's still some left in there and
it's going to make its way in there
but the other key thing about golf
courses is they tend to be the
collection area of watersheds so this is
an example here at cornell university so
obviously there's the golf course we
have two golf course greens here
near a water a water body a little pond
here on our fifth hole
but the other important factor here when
we see eutrophication in the summer
is to consider that there's a horse farm
here upstream
and when we get heavy rainfall events
water gushes across that horse farm
there's manure
right and that ends up in the water body
so
when we test golf course water bodies
it's important to consider uh what
what's the the total amount of water
that's coming in there and a lot of
times it's coming in from other land
adjacent to the golf course
so the way you can combat this uh is
with bmps and then the first one is
basic structural bmps planting
vegetation around these water bodies
a growing longer grass you can see in
this image longer vegetation that slows
the runoff rate allows infiltration
and can filter out those pollutants as
you're slowing that water down so
just an example here in kansas right
implementing these bmps uh reduces
nitrogen in the water it reduces
phosphorus uh reduces you know herbicide
degradation we see in there and okay it
starts to improve uh some of the
macroinvertebrates
species and richness
so these sort of bmps work and it's
really simple long grass right we can
think of it as just longer vegetation
again it's about slowing the rate of the
water going to that uh you know in this
case this is a stream here near montauk
at montauk downs slowing that water
allowing the vegetation in those root
systems to filter out those pollutants
as they go in there
uh and this these images are courtesy of
rick slattery who who did a lot of
implemented a lot of these long grass
areas
at locust hill when he was the
superintendent there
and they obviously look beautiful and
there can be strategic elements to them
um and this is kind of what it looks
like before right
and i think there's a lot of golf
courses that have these um you know i
would call them peripheral areas in
between two holes in between car paths
great candidates for long grass
conversion
and it's super simple you know rick you
know documented it well here with photos
lining it out to start
allowing it to grow up
in the course of the first year maybe
you make a an herbicide application just
to control some weeds but this is in
august that same year and and uh you've
already got a really cool
long grass area um it does more than
more than just filtering pollutants and
runoff that's what we're talking about
today but carbon emissions savings right
you're mowing that area unless um you've
reduced your time to manage that area
you can reallocate that labor elsewhere
biodiversity right you've got longer
longer grass in there you're going to
have some
some smaller animals running around
you're going to have pollinators
probably if you have flowering weeds
well or flowering vegetation
so it's good for those
those environmental purposes
and if you're a golf geek like me
there's strategic
implications to long grass for good
players and also we call it vertical
scale so a lot of times architects will
talk about
playing corridors left to right the
scale of a golf hole
but that also pertains vertically so uh
longer grass gives that vertical element
it it's like topography it's like
bunkers it's like trees getting your eye
to go up and down
so there's some some golf reasons to do
it
but if you'll notice you know we have up
here in the top corner
this is an eagle and and if you followed
our program we have these bmps as par
birdies and eagles
uh and eagles are kind of the ones that
that we've deemed uh most difficult to
achieve
and so you're probably wondering well
hey you just told me it's super easy to
to put long grass in why is it an eagle
and it's because we have golfers
um long grass equals golfer disruption
and and i'm sure some of you watching
this
have had times if you've tried to create
long grass areas
a golfer comes up to you and says
i hit my ball i couldn't find it in
there i don't like that long grass
so the reality is that we have golfers
we have greens committees
gm's who will ask us these questions
about
you know i we don't want to lose our
golf ball we don't want to have slow
play
so you have to think about how you
balance these reduced inputs the
environmental benefits
of long grass with golfers actually
recreating on your landscape
and you can do that through data and
this is some really really cool data we
did for a case study in this project
we partner with the usga
and their deakin system
and through this system you can get a
service where you hand out gps data
loggers to your golfers
and this is an image of our cornell golf
course
where we each those each time you hand
out that logger it tracks their location
across the whole golf course
and you can generate maps like this
and this is great for a whole bunch of
reasons
uh but today what uh you know what we're
talking about is long grass and one of
the case studies that we looked at was
identifying areas on the golf course
these peripheries that have low traffic
so we're seeing a bunch of
large areas where you know maybe we have
one or two golfers coming in there
but we measured 185 golfers so this
gives us really good data
to go in and and you can advocate to
your gm to your greens committee
you know hey we're seeing less than one
percent of people go in these areas
uh it's two acres it's three acres we
could save a whole lot uh from reducing
mowing in there
and we can can have these uh
water filtration benefits as well
so you can find that
uh case study online i'll drop a link in
the chat below here in a bit
uh talking about the the things we
quantified in that case study
and i encourage you to check out that
deacon system it's it's good for a lot
of reasons but
this is what we focused on here
so all these things i'm talking about
are really about non-point source
pollution and what that means is
you can't point to the spot where it's
coming from it's a landscape scale
and there's these structural controls we
can use around water bodies right longer
vegetation detention areas
those help reduce non-point source
pollution risk
and then of course just reducing your
chemical use right less fertilizer less
pesticides
are really the two ways you're going to
prevent non-point source pollution
but then there's point source pollution
and as i transfer over here
uh tarik slattery who's gonna to take us
the way the rest of the the webinar uh
point source pollution as the name
suggests is you can point at it
and on a golf course
uh where you're generally going to be
able to point to pollution
is the maintenance area so uh happy to
introduce rick slattery uh former golf
course superintendent uh rick you're
gonna walk us through a bunch of bmts
today uh relating to that maintenance
facility and how you can produce uh
point source pollution
thank you kyle and uh
i'll start with uh
i'd like to just start with some overall
comments about the maintenance facility
in general
and uh as part of our erp program and
it's on our erp poster
uh
that we do have a pro tip there that a
well-kept maintenance area reduces risk
and it speaks volumes about your
attention to detail
and uh
i can uh
i'll share with you something that
happened to me earlier in my career when
i was you know trying to climb the
ladder and trying to move on to better
clubs and that kind of thing
and uh i had had a visit from a greens
chairman
uh from a very prominent club in town
and he wanted to come to the maintenance
facility and uh so when he got there i
asked him you know why why'd you want to
come to maine's field facility and not
meet at the clubhouse or you know
off-site or something like that
and he said that in his experience
uh there was a direct correlation
between the upkeep of the maintenance
area and the upkeep of the golf course
and said he could tell how well i was
taking care of the golf course by just
looking at my maintenance facility
and it kind of made a made an impression
on me and uh you know i think throughout
my career i started looking at things a
little differently
and uh when i was at locust hill and we
were hosting the lpga one year i did ask
the lpj officials if they saw a
correlation
uh when on tour you know from golf
course to golf course because they saw
so many golf courses and you know our uh
you know
was that true for them you know did the
uh maintenance facility how that looked
did that kind of correspond with the
golf course and they verified that and
they said yep you know that's uh we do
see that and uh
so
any advice the advice i would i would
give is to take as much pride in your
maintenance facility as you do your golf
course
and you can tell by these two
before and after pictures here
if you were a member or a golfer walking
in your facility uh
which one would you know give you a
little better impression about the way
things were run
and so when i got to locust hill i
inherited a barn floor here
and it was when i inherited it was
unpainted and it was splintered and just
all beat up and
uh you know you can see that it was it's
amazing what a four-sander and uh some
epoxy can do every year uh with the
floor and first impressions and
you know our shop was was was uh used to
house lpga players during rain delays
and officials and everybody would kind
of come in there and uh you know we had
rain delays and so uh you know this
flora we got a lot of good compliments
on it and i think it gave a good good
impression to the players on the tour of
our facility
and uh you know i once worked out of a
barn with no bathroom and but we always
kept it neat
and clean and well organized and
whether we like it or not
first impressions do matter
uh as a power on our
on our erp poster
uh
we uh about floor drains here and just
my advice would be know where your floor
drains go
if anything for liability reasons
um
during at locust hill we had quite a few
environmental uh
insurance audits because we'd be doing
something in the clubhouse or changing
insurance companies and they i'd have an
audit or
somebody come in and do an inspection
and i can tell you the first thing they
always ask me when they walked into my
shop was where do the floor drains go
and i have to tell you that the first
time that happened i was a little
embarrassed because i didn't know
and uh i can tell you that we did find
out we traced them after they left and
and a couple of them were going into an
old abandoned septic area and we
immediately got those plugged up
and i can tell you another time i had a
pesticide inspection from the dec and
they walked into uh my pesticide room
storage room and we had a drain in there
with uh you know caulk so that if we had
a leak we could pump the chemicals out
and that was what they asked me first
thing was that was that floor drain go
and as soon as i told them it just went
to a crock you know they were fine with
it
so again advice my advice would be to
plug any floor drains that you do that
you have that might
not go into a holding tank
and the reason being we want to try to
avoid situations like this
and uh
you know this is uh i had i know a lot
of superintendents in my career that get
themselves in a little bit of trouble
and
a lot of times it was just because of
the dye that was in the tank you know
you rinse your tank out and you know the
dye goes into the water and goes behind
somebody's house and they see the dye
and all sudden they're all up in arms
about it and you can get a little
trouble so an out of sight out of my
attitude with with some of this stuff
can get you in a lot of trouble
so if you can't plug drains well what do
you do
one thing you want to do is just make
sure you you daylight them a sizeable
distance from the property boundaries
water bodies or any natural vegetation
border
before they can get to the get into the
water
if you do have a spill on site
we developed this spill control
procedure as part of the erp program
it's on our website
uh the website's listed right there
uh below on the left-hand bottom
left-hand side
and uh we had this vetted by uh some
people at dc and the people of b2i and
and this is what we came up to up with
and uh you know again uh go on our
website print this out
uh put it up in your shop somewhere
and make sure your staff
is aware of it and knows what to do in
case there's of spill
so what would be uh around the shop what
would be our biggest source of pollution
and a lot of fingers can be pointed
right to the to the equipment wash area
and you can see right here just by this
picture how much how much clippings and
and how how dirty the water rinse aid is
is coming from the equipment wash
operation and
in 2014 uh locust still was uh
certified by audubon international
and during that process they identified
a gap in our sustainability efforts
uh because we didn't have a closed-loop
wash system
and uh you know i explained to them that
the major barrier to this is is the cost
a lot of these commercially designed
systems can be 40 50 75 000 depending on
what you decide to get
and uh so
uh it wasn't too too long after that
that i was contacted by the new york
environmental leaders program and they
had seen we were certified by audubon
and they asked us if uh
if we want to join the program which we
did
and the first thing they asked me was uh
how can we help you was there anything
we can do to help
so i mentioned this gap in our
sustainability efforts and uh about the
wash pad
and so they can't that's when they uh
introduced me to the people at the uh
the pollution prevention institute that
was uh that's located at rit
uh in in rochester and
they are a friendly arm of the dec they
voluntary compliance uh they're there to
help businesses uh help them become more
efficient help them with any kind of
environmental problems that they might
have
and uh
you know they they supply the funding
and uh i can tell you here's the the
contact information
uh eugene park if you want to get a hold
of them and like i said they're very
helpful people
i've been working with them for about
six or seven years now and they're a lot
of fun and and just feel good to work
with
so
p2i decided to
take on the project and uh
and we set up some goals uh first we
wanted to clean the water of pollutants
uh we wanted to reduce water use if we
could
and the big thing was we wanted to
develop a system anyone can afford
not to replace the commercially designed
systems but it's an alternative
uh for people who uh where you might
have somebody breathing down your neck
and you just can't quite afford to put a
put a big system in there uh we wanted
to devise something that uh you could
you could go to
and also we want to minimize the time
needed for maintenance uh nobody wants
us no superintendent wants to spend a
lot of labor out at the at the wash pad
so the first thing we did was we put in
a couple uh gpm meters on our wash hoses
and that helped us
track the amount of water we were using
and uh with the idea that we wanted to
get the amount of water we're using as
small as possible so that we could keep
the system that we designed small
and
by keeping the
the system small that would keep the
costs down
and uh if you if you're interested uh
you can get you can buy one of these gpm
medias for anywhere between 20 and 75 on
amazon it's really not a big big
investment
uh the other thing we did
that we started doing to try to reduce
the amount of water we were using it was
blow off our equipment with air first
and we actually found that they've
reduced the the time that we were
spending
washing off equipment and it actually
reduced the water by 50 percent that we
were using
it extends extends equipment life
uh during the surveys that we did i
visited one golf course with the
superintendent all he used was there
and he just pointed to the fact that his
equipment lasted longer it was a
mom-and-pop operation and you know seals
bearings all that stuff just lasted a
lot longer
and i can tell you from
my people
they prefer staying dry go out there on
a 50 degree day or a 60 degree day and
start splashing water around for half an
hour and it's not a lot of fun
so
there's different process different
things you can use a compressed air here
uh we had a compressor in our shop and
all we did was put a small hooked up a
small pvc pipe to it and ran that out to
the wash area
and if you don't have anything like that
you can always use a backpack blower
uh the guys that were on our bigger
equipment like a fairway
rough mowers and big fairway mowers they
actually liked using the backpack blower
before uh
before they washed it off
and the second thing we found was just
don't use open-ended hoses just by
putting a nozzle and we found this at a
hardware store very cheap i think it was
under ten dollars or fifteen dollars
uh
and uh you can see here by the gpm meter
which you're choosing a little over six
gallons per minute
by just but just putting nozzles on the
hoses we're able to save another 30
percent
as far as water goes
and uh and then of course clipping
control um you know you have to have a
way to be able to control those
clippings
um we had a locus till uh wash pad here
this was uh put in you know maybe uh
1990 or so
and you can see just by having some
screening here in the trough how well
that does in cleaning so a lot of these
uh
uh you know clippings out of the rinsaid
and any any kind of a system you put in
there's gonna be some manual work with
just getting the clippings out of there
and collecting them and then composting
them or spreading them spreading them
out afterwards
and some of the surveys that we did the
fellas were which is an alternative
option
uh they were washing and blowing their
equipment off at multiple sites around
the course and the rough
away from water bodies and you know
that's a that's okay if that's uh
it's a lot better than just
uh any other any other option that they
have it's a good option
so what do we learn during the
feasibility stage
phase
using compressed air to blow off
equipment before washing reduced water
use by 50 percent
using compressed air also reduced the
clipping compound clipping content in
the washer and saved by 50
installing low flow nozzles on wash
hoses reduced water use by another 30
percent
installing water meters provided
valuable data on how much water was
being used for the wash operation
and water doesn't have to be perfectly
clean to wash equipment that's one thing
we found was you really don't need
drinking water to uh
to wash off equipment so if the system
that you're using
is not perfect
uh that's okay i mean the water doesn't
come out perfect that's that's quite
quite okay
and just simply using air before washing
using low flow nozzles and collecting
clippings just so if you just did those
three things alone that would make a
huge positive environmental impact
decision was made from there then to
phase two and design a prototype
uh going forward to see if we could do
that
so again some of the considerations were
was know the flow uh this goes back to
the gpm meters again
uh knowing what how much water we're
using so that we could size
the tanks in the system and obviously
less water means smaller tanks and a
smaller system and less cost
another consideration is you're going to
need some kind of wash pad and trough
uh and then
just for collecting the clippings um
and uh
if you put any system in whether you put
a commercial system in or whether you
whatever you decide to do
uh you're gonna need need a wash pad in
some way and a trough to somehow collect
those clippings and you can see the
screens that we had put in installed and
it's just that's just sheet metal with a
bunch of holes drilled in it
and as the uh you know as the clippings
built up uh in front of the screens we
just take a shovel and a rake there that
you see
and clean out in front of those screens
the other the other consideration is uh
it's electricity you're gonna need some
electricity to run some of this
equipment
so uh you know we actually installed
ours in in-house
and off this telephone pole here but
that's something you've got to consider
uh you're going to have to have
electricity somewhere near wherever you
put the system in
so this is the basic system and this is
an eagle as i said just uh blowing off
equipment and doing nozzling and
collecting clippings those are the
things we would recommend doing first
and then as you move to towards a
much better syst much better arrangement
uh
then you can go to these closing system
and this just shows
uh the basic components in the bottom
left-hand corner you see this black
holes coming out that comes from the
trough pumping the trough goes into the
sand filter here this is the major
component of the system and then for our
system here we had to have a transfer
drum and the purpose of that was just to
pump water from the bottom of the sand
filter into this top of the storage tank
and then we had a booster pump out here
that would pump water out of the storage
tank and into the hoses that we would
use for washing off the equipment and uh
you know as i said uh
a lot of this was just to create an
awareness of the situation in the first
place of how bad this this stuff is that
we're ejecting into the environment
locus toes and uh
on a good mo day we were we were uh
generating about 1700 gallons of water
before we started with this project of
that rinse aid out into the environment
um and then to provide an alternative to
the expensive systems if you can afford
an expensive system fine
as i said if there's people
uh breathing down your neck and you
don't have the money this is an
alternative
and we can as we go along i just we just
want to show
the results of this system
through the through the water testing
here
uh this is a a sample of water from the
from the wash pad itself
and you can see before it even entered
the system how how nasty that stuff
looks and then we had a hydro screen set
up up here
that basically it's like a washboard the
water goes into the bottom and it fills
up the back and it kind of runs down the
front and the water goes in and
the clippings kind of stay up on top you
can see after running it through the
hydro screen there was a little bit of
an improvement got some of the solids
out of there
and then it's transferred to the top of
the sand filter which is the key
components of the system
and you can see that
water coming on the third bottle here
the water coming out of the bottom of
the sand filter is a little cloudy a
little when it comes out
but it's much much much cleaner than
anything than when it came in
it came in the top
this is a good point to just show very
quickly the construction of the sand
filter
we started with a 1600 gallon tank here
and
from that as you look over to the top
right
uh we had a just a pvc pipe running
across the top of the tank with some
holes drilled in it
and that would accept the water from the
pump the pump would from the trough
would pump into this
and then these holes would sprinkle out
the water on top of the sand
uh the water would go down through the
sand and then down in the bottom here
we constructed a look what we call the
lower manifold just an x
same thing pvc pipe with some holes
drilled in it and then we covered up the
pipe with drainage stone
and over in the bottom right here you
can see the results with the uh water
coming out of a spigot that we installed
in the bottom of the in the bottom of
the tank
uh and then from there we had the the uh
challenge was how do we get the water
from the bottom of the sand filter up to
the top of the storage tank
and uh basically that's where this
transfer drum this blue drum comes in
here in the middle here
and
the hydraulic head
basically moves water down through the
sand filter
so
this pipe here that's horizontal
that determined the height of the water
in this in the sand filter
so obviously you raise this up there's
going to be more water in the sand fill
the lower and there's going to be less
so as water here is pumped in through
the upper manifold and it's dropped onto
the sand
and water fills up the tank the head
pushes the water out to this level here
and into the into the transfer drum
from there inside the transfer drum
there's a float and a sump pump inside
here and as the drum fills up the pump
kicks on and pumps the water to the top
of the storage tank and then inside the
storage tank we had another sump pump
operating just
circulating that water on the inside
keeping from keeping bacteria from from
building up inside the tank as it as it
sat there waiting to be used
and as you can see here again these are
the water bottles a lot of samples that
we took
and that first bottle is before it even
entered the system you can see how nasty
that looks and then as the water settled
out in the in the holding tank in the
storage tank that last bottle pretty
clean
and looks looks pretty good so it proved
that uh we were able we were we were
successful with the with getting the
contaminants out of the water and here's
some of the water test results we had
from locust hill
and uh you could see
the bacteria concentration in this first
this first column here
20 000 here after the hydro screen
and the water
after the sand filter it the same filter
just drops it down almost nothing 200
and then the hose out was 2200 so that
proved to us that we were getting a
little bacteria building up in the
holding tank as it sat around
and you can
you know add a uv light or some chlorine
tablets
in extreme situations but you see how
the turbidity dropped quickly cod
measurements dropped from 70 just about
down
to uh where it was safe to drink but we
never found any volunteers that
wanted to give it a try and give it you
know drink a cup to see if anything
would happen so
um
but
and the cost of the system we were able
to keep it down quite a bit uh you can
see it was about a little over five
thousand dollars
but that does not include the concrete
pad or the electricity
and uh and if you have tanks lying
around uh you know we got ours one of
ours from a fertigation old fertigation
abandoned system
and uh you know you can even drop those
costs down even more because you can see
that the tanks are probably the most
support most expensive part of the
system so if you can eliminate that you
can almost do this for nothing
so uh what do we what do we what did we
learn from and to improve watchpad
system 101.0 as we'll call it
uh
we we decided to locate the sump pump in
a wash pad trough inside a crock with a
float so that it would operate
automatically and i can show you a slide
of that in a minute
and we also want to look into locating
the bottom of the sand filter above the
top of the storage tank so we could
eliminate the transfer drum
and this would also keep the sand and
the sand filter dry which we're hoping
would would require less maintenance
overall
and possibly regrading of elevations uh
and then also
you could use a storage tank that's much
shorter in height but larger in diameter
and that can help you achieve the same
thing
and we discovered the hydro screen is a
little finicky and requires some main
ongoing maintenance as it's being used
so we want to look into ways to improve
the screening in the trough to remove
clippings more efficiently there so we
wouldn't need the hydro screen
and a circulation pump in the storage
tank limits buildup of contaminants
while the water is stored for use
uh one thing we thought of doing wasn't
just install a light sensor to turn the
pump on and off automatically because it
really doesn't have to run 24 hours a
day
it would be off during the day and on at
night
and as i said earlier extreme conditions
may require the addition of a uv light
or chlorine tablets to the storage tank
to keep that bacteria build up down
um
and uh we also found that uh you know we
were the system was capable of reducing
water use by 80 or 90 percent and that's
that's that's dramatic i think
so then we moved on to wash pad system
2.0 and we were very fortunate that a
famous golf course on long island i
won't say who it was they had 90 holes
and and five courses they stepped up to
the plate
and they partnered with p2i to build the
2o version
and they actually have they were so
successful with that that they have more
planned in the future
and this is a schematic that we put
together to kind of show
uh the differences between watch system
101 and watch system 2.0
uh first of all over here uh we wanted
to try to improve the screening in the
trough so that we could possibly
eliminate the hydro screen
again uh i'll show you a slide on this
how how the difference is but we also
want to install a crock
so that we could
put the sump pump in there and will
float so they would operate
automatically wouldn't have to turn it
on manually
and from here this is the big difference
where you pump to the top of the sand
filter
and
here the sand filter is located above
the bottom is located above the storage
tank and here the wash system here is
the sand filter is located on the same
level ground
so as again you can see that
this pipe here this horizontal pipe
determines the water level
in the sand filter
and the sand in the sand filter on this
wash that wash system 1.0 was always
staying wet which we felt
added to some of the contaminants that
would stay in the system
whereas watch pad 2.0 the sand is always
staying dry because immediately when the
water gets to the
bottom manifold it goes out and drains
directly into the into the storage tank
so eliminating this transfer drum by
just elevating this watch pad i mean the
sand filter
uh i think is is a big improvement
and uh going forward
and here are some photos of what what
i'm talking about there and again the
location of the tanks these are on level
ground here in 1.0 the top left hand
corner
uh this is this is watch system 1.0
and this is the transfer drum
and with 2.0 you can see they located
the sand filter above the top of the
storage tank so you can see this pipe
here
immediately when the water goes through
the sand filter it's draining off into
the storage tank this is just a side
view to show you the same
the same thing
and here on the left is wash system 1.0
with the screening we had you can see it
worked quite quite effectively
and uh worked well for us
but we also
had the pump we did not have a crack so
the sump pump was set down in here we
took the
uh grade off and would set the pump in
here and as the truck filled up with
water then we would turn the sump pump
on manually and as it got pumped down we
would turn it off uh turn it off again
so that was something we wanted to try
to improve upon which with the 2.0
version they did
uh they added a crack in here over over
here at the bottom they put it in a proc
and with an on off float so the the that
part of the system operated
automatically
they also improved the screening out
here in the trough uh they used some
chicken wire with some other other items
and they were labeled to eliminate the
hydra screen
and then here's just to show you real
quick the booster pumps with 1.0 i mean
we had a little larger booster pump
we supplied two hoses on off and as you
as you get
draining as you turn out a hose and and
downstream you start losing pressure
uh this this pump would kick on and
supply the hoses with water
um and with 2.0 they actually over here
on the right
they started with a pressure washer
and you can for smaller operations you
can just go down to home depot somewhere
and pick up a pick up a cheap pressure
washer to
to put on there
but they did find out later on they did
upgrade to a booster pump here and they
did find that that increased the
efficiency of the washing of the
equipment and they were able to get it
done a lot quicker
and this is some of the water tests we
had from wash system 2.0 that came in
and you can see the cod measurements
pre-treatment
1085
after the sand filter drops dramatically
it's down to 67
and the water coming out of the
power washer was a six so
some huge huge dramatic effects there
and just to give you a quick comparison
municipal wastewater can run between 300
and a thousand non-polluted surface
waters and less than 20.
so big improvement there with cleaning
the water and you can see that this is
that what their system cost them and
it's again it's it's down there just
over five thousand dollars uh they had
some wood here that was involved just to
make it pretty and
and build some stands and things like
that so you subtract the wood from the
total um you come out with a little over
five thousand five thousand dollars
which was what the watch system 1.0 cost
and again if you have tanks laying
around or other ways that you could
put in some tanks
um
you know that you could save a big a lot
of money there and like i said almost do
this for nothing
and just as a note the concrete wash pad
cost them about 10 grand
so depending on the size and how
elaborate you want to make it you could
you know you're going to spend 5 or 10
grand just for the wash pad but again
even if you were to put in a commercial
system
you're going to have to put a wash pad
in to collect the clippings and their
wiring their electrical wiring costs
about a little over two thousand dollars
um again we did ours in house for 1.0
and it didn't cost us anything
so what are the questions moving forward
um that we want to do we want it for 3.0
which we do have planned for for uh next
next year at the same golf course
uh how small can the sand filter be
given water volumes
again uh can we make the system smaller
than we were making them right now
uh
and still have them still be efficient
uh how long can the water be used before
recycling it
uh to be replaced or replace it
uh and we have been experimenting with
with harvesting rainwater
and uh you know during the rainstorm uh
the the wash pad and the trough will
fill up with water
and uh we found that you could pump that
into the system and and just replace
anything that you might have lost to
evaporation or whatever
and uh almost be
self-sufficient where you don't need any
municipal water at all
we're hoping uh where you can just
replace anything that you lose
uh with rainwater
and then how much difference does
actually elevating the sand filter make
to the maintenance of the system so we
want to look into that a little further
and to see if elevating that sand filter
and keeping that sand dry
how much does that actually make the
system much more efficient or not
and then we want to look into the
optimal sand type for filtration
and is there what properties of this of
sand
actually would work best in this
situation right now we're just using top
dressing sand that we have on site
and it's been working fine
but it would be interesting to find out
if we
um
if we
have uh
you know a sand that would work best so
with that i'll stop sharing my screen
and uh go back to the panel here
and
we'll proceed from there
all right thanks thanks rick um frank
we'll bring you in here and uh we want
to get your quick thoughts on
when you see all that just some quick
quick thoughts from you um and then
maybe questions you have for rick and
things
um that we can talk to our audience here
about and try and get them to think more
about uh
putting putting these types of systems
in yeah no doubt
so great to hear from you guys um
i want to start with uh both of you
carl you gave the information about long
grass being an eagle
showing the deacon approach
rick
you did this
can you talk about the first steps you
took
in trying to establish these long grass
areas
that might give some a superintendent
some practical uh tips to just how do
you start i'm not getting deacon i'm not
doing a gps how do i start um figuring
out how to go about this
oh i need real quick yep there you go
first it starts with the educational
part of this you want to whether you
have owners or a member of ship or
whatever you want to start communicating
the benefits of of having these areas on
the golf course i always felt that they
added depth to the golf course that was
the word i always used to use but i can
tell you it was a it was a little little
uh you know the first time i did it i
just went out and picked the areas and
without much thought
and i got my and we ended up cutting a
lot of them down because they were in
play areas you know to couple it and so
i lost some momentum on any momentum i
had in establishing those and
later on when we uh decided to become uh
certified by audubon that was one of our
one of their requirements
and so we just started small and that's
what i would tell anybody start small go
to these areas that are really out of
out of play i mean where there's no
chance of a golf ball going in there
and just just start
start there and then as as they became
more popular
and people started catching on and other
golf courses were doing it i was able to
develop more and more areas and add to
that
but that i would always say that up here
is it you know it depends on what you
want too if you want a perfect fescue
maintained you know whatever it's got to
be this or that a wispy
you know you can get into a lot of
maintenance with these things
and uh the bottom line is
uh when i started with mine i got the
best results by not mowing it all in the
spring
don't touch it in the spring at all
and
we just mowed it once in the fall
and maybe sprayed it for weeds in the
fall and that's all all we ever did
so
um but i would just say start small even
if you start with these vegetation
borders around around your water bodies
you know i started just by going down to
the water first we would fly more now
what what superintendent wouldn't like
to get rid of his slime holes and hang
them up not use them especially in this
day and age of labor you know labor is
so hard to find if locusts tell i had to
send four four to five guys out for
eight hours to do all that fly moaning
around our water bodies
now not only is that a lot of labor i
could use other other means but we were
putting all those clippings into the
water getting algae blooms because of it
so i started just going down to the
water's edge and letting the aquatic
weeds kind of come up a little bit and
then just slowly every time we fly mode
maybe come up a couple inches then
another couple inches and a couple of
inches and i got it up a certain depth
and then i could almost see where you
know golfers started getting a little
uncomfortable with it so we stopped
but the key to that is to keep the weeds
out you know the members and the golfers
don't like the weeds
but i guess my my advice would be to
start small and start out of the way and
don't go big
you know right away just start small
i guess the other thing i'd ask is um
the question i get
a lot is um okay
i can do this buffer around water
um
and it's a no spray zone
so what do i do there what happens when
weeds come
what are the management okay not mowing
and you learn pretty quick how many
weeds mowing actually controls because
you start to see plants in there you
don't normally see now
in the last bunch of years we've been
able to transform
the
uh perception of milkweed
from a weed to a like oh we gotta have
milkweed for the monarchs
and so my question is this rick
how do you manage a no maintenance
zone a no spray zone around these water
bodies without
a little bit of
spot treats how do you go about
managing 25 to 50 and if pesticide
labels are followed
hundred foot
borders
around water bodies
yeah um
well i could tell you how i did it and
you you know people it's it's amazing
when you when you think of something it
might be overwhelming at first
but
i would just sense some guys up there
when it like i said the grassy stuff and
the low growing stuff even clover and
stuff like that that didn't bother
people too much because when you get the
you know the uh uh
you know golden rod and things like that
these big long stemmy things would come
out
and i can tell you you know once a month
i'd send a couple guys up to the edges
of the creeks and the ponds and just
pull that stuff out manually and
if you look at that and while
i was spending uh you know uh four or
five guys and eight hours a week to
to trim this stuff what is it to send a
couple guys up to there every once in a
while to just pull some of the unsightly
weeds out
now
that worked for me and uh but that's
that's something that uh
uh i would say i mean but that is that
is a uh
it's a bmp and we've we've gotta we
gotta learn how to figure we gotta
figure it out
and uh as you just mentioned we're
seeing the a lot of the new chemicals
are coming out with this hun you know we
we say this all the time it's like well
we're trying to tell you this stuff so
that you'll know about it and you can
kind of prepare for it and kind of get
ready for it
and what do we do we wait till it's
legislated
and what's happening is all the new
chemicals are coming out with that
hundred foot no spray zone around water
bodies and that that's how they're
getting around it so we could do it
voluntarily
or we can
wait until every label we're using is
listed like that so
if you got to figure it out but you know
as far as weeds you know just a couple
guys going up through once a while was a
lot less labor than trying to trim those
things every week
carl what about from a golfer's
perspective you know you know
you're our guy here and certainly rick
before he threw the clubs away was quite
the golfer
uh but but from a golfer perspective
you know i know you're a played of
course as it is right no matter how bad
the bunkers are
sometimes that's an inside joke if you
know you know
um
so how do you think about these things
from a golfer's perspective because
you're right and rick mentioned it it is
a bit navigating around play
without data just as a golfer how do you
think about these things when you see
them now yeah i think the prevailing
view is that golfers um so for example
they see long grass on tv
whether it's uh at a place like beth
page at shinnecock at the at the open
championship right across
across the ocean and they see players
who find their golf ball and can hit
their golf ball out now there's a couple
things there one those forces
they do in manage those areas and
whether it's herbicides or growth
regulators
but but that's championship level
conditioning they need to be able to to
find the ball keep it wispy keep it thin
at most of the golf course we're
targeting uh that's probably not
feasible and
uh so the first thing i'd say is is you
have to communicate expectations to
golfers you know rick rick you were
talking about you know domo during the
spring so there'll probably be a one to
two month period where golfers will find
their ball where it hasn't really hit
that lush
growth yet and there may be one or two
months in the year where it's just gonna
be hard to find your ball
now what i've talked to i've talked to
you know our director of
the new york state golf association
about this
and he recommends putting a red line
around those areas and treating them as
hazards that way if you don't find your
golf ball under the rules of golf you
can take a drop
right next to the long grass area you
don't have to walk all the way back to
the tee because you didn't find your
golf ball
so so that's what he recommends that's
what i would say too it's a lot easier
to
if it's a thick area keep people out of
it keep people walking around we have
milkweed we'd like people not to trample
that in in some of these long grass
areas um so when it gets really thick
you know you can label it as a long
grass area you can have that on your
scorecard local rule long grass areas
play as
um as a penalty area um so that's what i
think
from a golfer's perspective i will say
one of my one of my good friends
says that if there's long grass on a
golf course he expects to find his ball
100 of the time that is not a reasonable
expectation i i i can't recommend that
to anybody you should not expect to hit
your to find it at all
okay and let me just add and this is so
brilliant carl thank you for ending on
that because try try as we might
what i would say is if you can stop 20
percent of people from going in there
you're going to keep the pace of play
going the problem is my father-in-law
doesn't care if he finds his ball he
finds five other people's balls when he
goes in there so that's you know a good
note to end on let's move uh to the wash
let's move to a couple of simple things
fellas i just want to draw some
attention some things you said
the drains okay
what's with the drains if anybody
listening watching the video
rick did you have drains and how did you
handle them and when you went and
visited
places recently
are people always aware of the drains
that they have or is it like oh yeah
there's a drain there i never thought
about that what is it
i think it's a combination of both
i mean i think you heard me say that the
first time i had a
insurance auditor come in and
he asked me where my dreams went i
didn't know where they went i never had
never i admit i had not given it a
thought and i was embarrassed
and so i when he left i made sure that i
found out where they went and everything
like that but it's so simple we have it
as a power on our uh on our poster it's
such a simple thing to do just know
where they're going
um
you know if you don't if it's
daylighting out there like one of those
photos into a stream or anywhere
and you don't you don't know that i mean
that is something you should know at
least that's that's potentially could be
a liable situation
so unless it's going on some kind of a
holding tank
it's so simple you go down to home depot
pick up a bag of cement and you plug it
up or whatever you got to do
um but again i mean uh it's it's it's
it's a very liable uh
potentially big environmental problem
that can be solved very easily just by
figuring out where these things let me
ask you you said something that boy i've
not heard before but i don't know why
i've not thought of it before
um you said an insurance person came by
and asked you about it yeah is it common
in your experience
that insurance people walk around
maintenance facilities looking for these
kinds of things i didn't necessarily
think it was
particularly common
but
boy wouldn't that be great if you could
get
insurance premiums lowered
because you did these bmps
i think so i think that's a possibility
but what it was was whenever we changed
insurance companies the new company
would send over an auditor and go
through the whole club
and look at possible liable situations
obviously to establish your insurance
rates and see how much liability they
were taking on by bringing in
and also with the tournament i mean i
would we you know once
i had a couple people from insurance you
know during the lpga that stopped in to
check things out
and also whenever you do a project 50
golf course they want you to do an
environmental review study
and that's part of it they're going to
come down to your shop they're going to
look into look at your main how you're
storing your pesticides which hopefully
all of us will store them also from our
site now and just bring them in when we
need them
but it just it was a shock to me i mean
when this fellow he was from the we had
just we were changing insurance
companies and he walked in
first time it was early in my career at
local still he says where do your floor
drains go
and it's just it scared me you know and
i kind of went
you know and it kind of embarrassed me
and
but yeah i mean it's such a simple thing
and it's just to create that awareness
of everybody should know where these
things go
and if they don't like again if they're
daylighting or going out of the
environment somewhere you got to get
them plugged you know it's a huge liable
situation all right one more thing
because we only have a few more minutes
um and i want to make sure i get this uh
question asked
um
we don't have to get it the water
completely clean in a wash
system um and
the hydra the hydra screen
tends to be a pretty expensive implement
it looks like in 2.0 rick
um
what happened at that very famous golf
course on long island that we were work
routinely with
uh was able to do
um
got the water almost as clean as the
hydra screen you had up there where you
were
um can but before that too
i know you measure you know you did a
couple of things that i want to make
sure you talk about again
how much water you use
blow the equipment off
find a nozzle that works that doesn't
waste water those three things seem to
me to be the front line
and then it looks like the screen thing
is doesn't need to be as expensive to
just clean it out a little bit can you
talk a little bit about that whole
process of
saving a little bit of you know big
things like getting the clippings off
and then cheaper ways to screen it
yeah uh
basically as we went through our project
and you if you look at our erp poster
now the easier easiest things to do are
to just blow blow your equipment off
first with air
and then to put a nozzle on your hose
and to try to collect the clippings and
so if you can do those three things or
even just the first two things just blow
air blow blow everything off of there
and then uh you know put a put a nozzle
on your hoses those things there can
make a huge impact and
and then uh as i said uh the hydra
screen
uh you know basically uh we were trying
to look at ways that possibly we could
screen the water
uh before it got into the sand filter
that's all it is is that the sand filter
holds up much better
uh you know there is a little bit of a
layer that will form on top of the sand
so you got to scrape that off you know
maybe once a month or something like
that but it's very minimal but we're
just looking at ways to keep that
the quality of the sand and the sand
filter as good as we could for as long
as we could so the better you can take
you know clean the screens out of the
water uh before it goes into the sand
filter the better off you are and so we
pass that information along to that
famous golf course
that you work with
and uh you know so they and it's about a
hundred dollar cost for the hydro screen
that if you can do that down in the pad
or something like that with some chicken
wire or some sheet metals with holes in
it and things like that then uh you know
then you can eliminate the the hydro
screen itself
so uh
but you know overall i think it like i
said if you've got a couple tanks laying
around
and you've already got a wash pad or a
trough we can collect clippings i mean
you can do it do it real cheap and it's
really for the guys that you know you've
got somebody breathing down your neck
maybe
a lot of the stuff is
local municipalities now uh they'll come
looking at you we had a situation where
you know we were daylighting hours quite
a ways away from our property lines but
it was adding water and
members uh some of the people had some
drainage problems because of it
and also you know as much as before we
had the closed loop system you know
there's the smell of the degrading you
know clippings that's not a very good
smell for members
neighbors to be just smelling
so uh you know
and so you know that that can happen to
somebody else and so i was saying is
you know if if you can afford a big
great commercial system go ahead
but if you got people breathing down
your neck and you can't afford that that
there are this is an alternative and you
can almost do it for nothing you know if
you have some tanks laying around so
it's really just the cost of the tanks
and then some some some other things on
top of that and you've got a way to
clean the water and and reduce we uh we
we do we were using like i said 1700
gallons on a mole day and uh you know we
got that down to nothing almost nothing
well let's just let let me stop you
there and call we'll wrap up in a second
but rick this is the thing
even if you're gonna go buy a turnkey
situation right
you can size it less if you clean the
clippings off you don't need to buy his
bigger one this is the thing that i like
the most about this project is you can
build it our way or you can go get one
but there are some really critical
things that you should know some due
diligence you should do
to understand how to size this thing
right and effectively have something you
can maintain right because no matter
what you've got
some aspect of this system is going to
require some maintenance
generally in one way shape or form so i
think uh
no matter how you go the principles are
there size it right keep the water clean
carl i'll pass it back to you you get us
out of here yep thanks guys uh so frank
uh people can expect a guidance document
on this uh in the in the next year or so
we're going to try and develop a
document that outlines all the
components of this system so
you know rick as you're talking about
certain components
you know we're going to try and provide
options at each step
um that can get you to something that's
going to work for your facility you know
what size it is whether you need to
recycle water or not those sorts of
things so
expect a guidance a guidance document
here coming up soon
thanks to all our live attendees uh a
very familiar uh bunch thank you guys as
always for tuning in and thank you guys
for watching this video uh with our erp
project we hope you learned something
we'll see you guys next time
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu